riding under a heated blanket
i've never done that anybody can learn
this right here right now go use it for
your own creative processing and it will
make such a world of difference you
would never take a coffee mug filled
with dirt to clean water and then drink
the water like you would want to clean
the coffee mug out first right we're the
coffee mug what day are you going to
start writing
wow today today
kara polson in the house
i'm so excited to be here
so i met kira at a genius event in
april
mm-hmm yeah april um and she she
said that she was uh
she helps you channel your book
and she we had a quick conversation and
i forget what you told me my next book
was it was either my throat or my heart
or something you you kind of in your
heart in your heart yeah it is in my
heart my next book and so i said this is
this is really cool and um it's
basically to help people get out of
creative blocks you know this is what
kiara's an expert at i'm using my words
but she can you know describe it better
probably herself as well but if you're
in a creative film to create a block
she's she's the go-to person and
specializes in helping authors get their
books out so if you're stuck with
writer's block or trying to figure out
how do i get this book out i mean i'm
sitting on a blank page you don't know
what to do kira is your go-to expert um
does that does that actually sum up what
you do i know you do a lot more but how
was that for an intro it's beautiful it
was beautiful i i own a publishing house
that's dedicated to authors bringing
through sacred books which are books
that are going to transform humanity and
those books can't come through with our
minds they have to actually channel
through our bodies and
[Music]
we do that by opening up and receiving
and that's really what i help people do
so my first book was a long slog to
write
like every week showing up at whole
foods and taking the whole day off and
writing my book and it took me maybe a
year to write that book the second book
was
now that you're talking about it feels a
lot more channeled i wrote that book so
quickly yeah uh i wrote a i wrote a
third of the book on a trip to new york
and back
i had a broken neck at the time
and i couldn't drive or fl i couldn't
fly because flying with a broken neck is
impossible they won't let you on the
plane and i couldn't drive because i
couldn't turn my head but i had to get
to new york for a meeting so my wife
drove us
nine hours each way to new york and back
and uh i wrote the book
i wrote a third of the book built the
serve
sitting next to her then just like i
couldn't keep up with the pace of like
the thoughts were coming through uh so i
know it's definitely possible i i
wouldn't have called it channeling or
you know i wouldn't have vocabulary for
it so
you know now we do and it's awesome yeah
so i love it
so do we wanna do we wanna
workshop it do we want to like what's
what's the best use of this to kind of
demonstrate to people how they can get
their book out of them
well i'll say that for me i use the word
channeling but it really is just
stepping into flow and i have a method
that we use that trains the body and the
mind to be able to actually step into
that flow at all times so what i would
love to do is we'll do that method right
here with you we're gonna just drop in
together and then if you are a full holy
hell yes i say that like everything in
your body has to be like i am a yes to
do this then we'll actually channel and
see what book is here waiting for you
okay let's do it do i yeah you ready
i'm using i'm using my hands to hold the
phone is that okay or do i need a
standard okay okay okay okay so what i'm
gonna do is we're gonna actually do what
i call the sacred creative process we're
gonna do it together right here right
now it's how i always drop in this is
the method i use to drop in and channel
at any time so i like to say that i have
five kids right so i have five kids
which means that i don't have like lots
of pockets of like silence it's not like
i'm like and then i have eight hours to
write a book like no i like have
literally 15 minute pockets in between
work and raising kids
this is how i bring through books super
fast is so that at any time like i've
written books at a trampoline park
because
that's the only place i could do it my
kids were all jumping and i could
receive anybody can learn this right
here right now go use it for your own
creative processing and it will make
such a world of difference so it's going
to be super weird for a lot of people
because i work with our spiritual team
and i work with angels so we're going to
do it from top to bottom i'm not going
to explain it because of time but we're
going to just do it together and then
we're going to invite your book to come
sit with us okay okay let's go
so i want you to take a deep breath in
all the way to your lower belly
breathing out
now we're just gonna do one more breath
in we're just gonna get into our bodies
and out
so now we're going to ask that this
divine light which is like a cleaning
light will come through the top of our
heads this is the crown chakra so just
take a nice deep breath in
we're going to let this light move all
the way through us from the top of our
heads all the way down to our toes
cleaning cleansing clearing the pathway
then we're gonna allow this light to
come up and around us sealing it up at
our toes to be an added form of
protection and to infuse and insulate us
with light then we're going to call in
all of our angels our guides our leaders
our teachers our helpers our healers the
ascended masters who've been assigned to
us
in and through the divine light to lead
guide and direct this session to be in
our highest good
we're then going to ask that light will
touch our ears so we may spiritually
hear what needs to be heard the light
will touch our third eyes we'll have
access to all of our spiritual gifts the
light will cleanse our lips that we may
speak only what needs to be spoken then
we're just going to ask all of our
angels who are here to support us that
they will actually hold the container
really clean
so that we can hear
if there is a book that's like waiting
to come so we're just going to ask for
that help that support that guidance so
take a nice deep breath in all the way
to your lower belly
and out
so now i'm going to keep my eyes closed
because it helps me hear better
so we're just going to ask
so we're going to ask your book to come
through
in and through the divine light to come
and like sit
at
the seat right here next to us and as
soon as i opened up to see your book it
came it showed up like a comet
like it has that much force
power light and
it has that much effect a comet doesn't
hit the earth
and just give it a tiny little ding
right like it comes in and it makes a
whole crater in the earth so i want you
to see that your book showed me like
it's actually here
like hot ready to go and this one's here
to like actually form a huge crater like
make a massive massive difference so
when i just say that what do you feel in
your body
excitement
right
yeah
oh am i opening my eyes or not yeah you
can open your eyes okay okay okay okay
okay
good i wasn't sure if i was still even
holding the phone properly yeah uh yeah
that's like that's exciting
yeah yeah
so now like i love that as soon as we
opened up it showed up even before i
came i asked it to come sit by us so
here's why i call myself a book medium
because
i actually experience books like mediums
experience spirits books show up next to
me and they have an essence a soul a
presence which in my heart means they're
already written
they're already created
you just need to birth it through and
when we try and figure out the book
we're messing with the system
we're making it so hard that's what
creates writer's block we're trying to
write the book the book is already
written
so if you just allow the book to come
and teach you
it will come through so quick so so so
fast just like you experienced so we're
gonna actually ask the book some
questions okay
all right okay you have to write this
down
okay just in case okay yeah
um
do you want me to tell you what i what i
heard and saw or or
i would love to hear yes oh okay well
this is gonna sound out there so when
you said uh angels
[Laughter]
okay so when you said angels
matthew mcconaughey came to me
wait this is so good
and and he said the book is about
momentum
so that that's what i got and then and
then i thought and then and then i then
then it felt honestly i was trying to
force the thought out to try to think
okay well what else maybe maybe listen
matthew somebody else maybe has a
message from me there's other angels
here let's let's kind of be open and and
i couldn't i couldn't it was kind of
like locked after that moment so
everything else would not like break
through
unless it was matt mcconaughey talking
about telling me momentum um
so that's what that's what happened
and it's super interesting that the way
it presented itself to me was a comet
which is like
massive momentum right
so there's like two witnesses okay here
we go we've got momentum on
on the table
okay
your heart is just so loud okay so i
wanna just like we're gonna go into your
heart because what happens
is that when we're invited to be a
vessel so a vessel is like something
that you pour something through right
we're gonna pour this book through you
you're gonna be the vessel that births
it
there are places in our body that wants
to re like
like not let it through like it gets
stuck it gets caught and there's
something here in your heart that if we
could open it up
like this book is going to
be all the magic
okay okay so i like to be all the magic
this is great okay i really wanted
presents like how gifted you are that
you were able to see that so quickly so
can we just like honor you
evan as like having really powerful
gifts and so now we're going to invite
your gifts to actually show up as we go
into your heart okay okay let's go
mcconaughey come on mcconaughey give me
your wisdom we're ready you can just
come sit next to us over here the book's
over here we can have him here
on my shoulder whispering let's go that
feels good so i want you to drop into
your heart so how you do that is you
close your eyes you're gonna take your
heart down your eyes down into your
heart space
and when you breathe into your heart and
even open up your shoulders and allow
your heart to expand
and then we're just going to ask what's
the message in the heart is the heart
like wanting to share something with you
is there a vision an image words a
feeling what are you present to
um
just the words all you're missing is
momentum
so write that down i'm gonna write that
down write that down write that down
oh you're doing one handed here
missing
okay okay so now i want you to ask your
heart what does momentum look like like
what ex ask what the message or
the definition of momentum is for you
right here
um
what so who am i asking what am i asking
we're
what does momentum mean what does
momentum mean for me because it's saying
all i'm missing is momentum what does it
mean
got it um
taking action
stop judging yourself
yeah expect to suck at the beginning
create create create
okay all right so this is a little far
out are you are you okay with that
that what i said was far out no what i'm
going to share with you what we're about
to do is okay i don't even know what i
said what did i say i love what you said
okay i don't know exactly what you said
except that you said it's you just have
to take action it's going to suck out
create
create
okay
so what i saw when you were saying that
because i received visually that's how i
received is i saw you with like these
handcuffs and you're like
chained to something and then all of a
sudden as soon as you said you're gonna
suck at the beginning the chains broke
okay and then it was literally like
it was a little wobbly at first and then
you just ran like
um oh dash i don't know if you i can't
remember your kids but you know on that
disney movie dash on the incredibles how
he runs so fast
okay have you seen that movie no no i
have i have a i have a 13 year old but i
haven't seen dash
incredible baby baby flash right yes
yeah yeah yeah okay
so the vision was as soon as you just
took action it felt a little wobbly at
first and then you were like dash like
the comet that i saw so
full of light speed action momentum
uh liberation expansion right
okay
so now now that we like open so what
that did is that just like opened your
heart here like
your heart is like oh my gosh you're
going to bring it through
like there's like a relief can you feel
it a little bit
that's exciting yeah yeah
so now i wanna we're gonna bring your
book and we're gonna put it right here
in between us like if we have this
beautiful table right here okay we're
gonna
place it right here okay and i want you
to close your eyes and i'm gonna sit
here with you and hold this space but i
really feel like because i can feel like
you're super gifted i want you
to hear if your book has a message to
tell you
so we're just going to ask your book if
it has a message to share with you what
is the message it has for you
just get going i just don't get get
going is on loop
yeah
get going is on repeat
okay
this is so fun okay
this is this is what your this is what
your book just showed me yeah is that
when you actually just start writing it
it showed me that it's gonna be like
these shoes that are like that have like
you know like the the
the things that make you jump really
high underneath them almost like moon
boots springs yes yes yes so it's like
when you start on this book
the amount of energy that you're gonna
get oh interesting because you are also
a trampoline jumper how interesting yes
yes yes so it's almost like your book's
like you're gonna get so much higher in
everything
when you bring this book through it's
like massive
height that's what i keep hearing so is
that the cover is it shoes with springs
on it
it might be we're like
like a comet coming over you
all right i like it
oh i love this book this book has a lot
of joy
yeah yeah this book has a lot of joy
so
now you get to commit to your book and
let your book know
what day are you going to start writing
wow
get going
so today today
yes oh that feels so good
okay
so here's my invitation
okay
you watched the you know you heard my
spiel at genius network on how to
channel your book
my invitation is is sit down
and just use that practice every time
you sit with your book
and really like open up and receive that
what you're gonna write you don't
actually know yet
right
like what's gonna come through evan's
hands is gonna actually be
teaching you information that you didn't
even know before you began i'm gonna i'm
gonna move the phone here so i can type
with two hands it's happening so fast i
can't keep track of it okay
yeah i love this book this book has got
some brilliant
magic energy
i need to find your sheet too again that
was an awesome little handout that you
gave you have an extrovert
nice very okay i will i'm gonna have my
friend miranda who's in my mastermind
she's written a book
so quickly she's got actually three
books coming through she's gonna put the
link to my free masterclass so everybody
here can just learn the same process
that we just did for free so that
anybody here wants to know what we're
talking about
they'll get
literally a free class on how to channel
their book just like what we did at
genius network
cool on youtube we can link that up
we'll put on youtube you can put in the
description below perfect
perfect um
what do we even do again so so hold on
then we i just was follow along in the
process without really paying attention
so we we we breathe we kind of relax a
little bit so we first step is we clean
the vessel right yeah so it's like you
would never take a coffee mug filled
with dirt
to clean water and then drink the water
like you would want to clean the coffee
mug out first right we're the coffee mug
right we kind of get dirty all day long
energetically because we go to work and
we raise people and we go to walmart and
all these things right
so we have to clean our vessel first so
that's what we did we clean the vessel
with light
and then we we
call in all of our angels now there's a
piece that we didn't do here
on the live smell the smell right the
smell so let me find my smell what's my
smell
can you what should i use my smell oh my
gosh can you channel that can you tell
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna go
buy some right now i gotta get going
okay so there's two smells that are
showing up
there's a blend that you can find with
doterra that's called cheer it's yellow
c-h-e-e-r
cheer
i like it yeah that's like um an oil for
you or
anything what's in it what's sorry
what's in the cheer
i don't even know
what does it kind of smell like like
flowers like um it's
well funny enough i don't remember i
don't have a sense of smell i don't know
if i told you that i lost my like six
years ago yeah
yeah it's the whole thing except i can
smell really lost your sense of smell
but your first thing is to tell people
the smell that's so wild okay because i
can smell rosemary it's the only smell i
can smell which is why it's like a big
part of my practice it's really
interesting it's the only thing you can
smell it's the only thing i can smell
like if somebody's
squirted an orange at you or something
or like somebody farted as they walked
by like you wouldn't smell it only
rosemary only rosemary
which is actually why this became a part
of my channeling process because
smell became such an important piece
to my creation yeah so i have no idea
what sure smells like but i'm just
seeing that i'm also seeing any sort of
um
citrus so any sort of like orange i said
orange yeah
yeah so any sort of orange feels like
what would be a good smell for you so
how we start the process is we first
smell the same smell every time and that
actually trains our minds and our bodies
to know when we're going to drop into
flow
so smell is a really important piece we
just didn't do it here first so you're
going to smell first then
you're going to pour light to your body
clean it out we did shield ourselves i
do really enjoy shielding that feels
super clean
so i don't know if you remember but when
we poured light through our bodies the
light went to our toes we asked the
light to create a shield of light around
us
oh yeah okay because if we're gonna
channel it feels smart
right
feels smart so we smell
we use light to clean shield and then we
call in our angels
right so we called in all of our angels
and i like to call on our angels our
guides our leaders our teachers our
helpers our healers the ascended masters
who've been assigned to us like all the
whole team in
right like we got like big work to do
we're going to call the whole team in
it's not always matthew yeah i thought i
was gonna be matthew right
you know matthew's a great guy that's a
great guide for you
it's crazy
okay wait and where am i getting cheer
or citrus what is there a brand that i'm
looking at um well so i know doterra has
cheer
but you can get
uh d-o-t-e
okay
um but you can get citrus essential oils
at any place right like just go to any
place you can get an essential oil you
can get
orange
um there's a few other ones
i can't think of them off the top of my
head it just feels like you need a
citrus smell though i feel like cheer
has citrus in it
i'll look at it afterwards
i'll go i'll buy it today we're gonna
get going momentum we gotta get going on
this okay so we call it our angels and
then we give them an assignment so i
don't know if anyone remembers when we
called in our angels we gave them an
assignment we asked them to hold the
space so that we could hear from evan's
book
and so i give my my spiritual team
assignments like i need 30 minutes of
pure silence so i can write
i need
um
this
you know sometimes we like have all this
noise in our mind i can ask my angels
hey can you hold the noise in my mind
for 30 minutes so i can just be a vessel
i'm not going to ignore the problems
that i have but can we just like put
them on the shelf sit again can you can
you hold what did you say can you hold
the noise so you have a noise noise in
our minds right like chatter
fears
all the things that want to stop us
you can ask your angels to clear it out
so you can be a vessel so just give them
assignments right
the final thing we did was what i
i called prepping to receive so we could
spiritually hear what needs to be heard
we blessed our third eyes we'll have
access to all of our spiritual gifts we
bless our lips that we speak only what
needs to be spoken but when we write we
bless our arms all the way down to our
fingertips that we write only what needs
to be written
and when you do this five step process
every single time you now train your
mind to know when to receive when to
step into flow
i like it now you started at the
beginning also with a
uh
along the lines of like this has to be a
hell yes we're not doing it kind of
thing right
is that is that a part of it like even
before going to the smell like you have
to be willing to do this or
even if you're reluctant it's going to
work well it has to be a holy hell yes
when i'm in a channel you like your book
with you because i have to know your
body's a yes for me to to do this work
with you when people are writing books
there's going to be times that you're
not going to want to write
it's different then right then you just
get to ask your angels to really help
you
get into the space of wanting to write
so that'll be their assignment so you
still you still lead with the smell and
the cleaning even if you may not be
fully into it 100
yeah okay are people's angels usually
like people like matthew mcconaughey or
is it a i guess it's very different
you know what it's very different one of
my angels is joan of arc
she comes in quite often yeah and she is
wow fierce as hell like she is
um she has no um
like i was talking last i was asking her
about self-doubt because i you know i
coach these masterminds of authors and
self-doubt is so loud and so i was like
all right joan like tell me how did you
do what you did without self-doubt and i
just got this vision of her
pounding her feet her fist on the ground
and she said two feet in
there's no room for doubt like it's not
on the table like she showed me if
there's no potatoes on the table
you don't eat potatoes for dinner if you
don't put self-doubt on the table it's
not an option
and when we are here to like massively
change humanity
like it's two feet in
it's just two feet in and self-doubt
just isn't on the table and that was her
message for me what a hero holy cow joan
of arc
you know this is this is um i used to do
a a version of this and i for whatever
reason got away from it but whenever i
struggled with a problem
i would imagine a
board of advisor it's a very like
business kind of way of thinking about
it but
who's my board of advisors and i think
about all my favorite entrepreneurs of
all time like okay i'm sitting at the
table and there's steve jobs and there's
you know all these people and then i'm
asking hey what what should i i guess it
wasn't really like giving them an
assignment it's more what what should i
do and then they would they would i
would do this like as i was going to
sleep or as i was waking up kind of when
i'm already in a weird like
between zone mindset um
yeah i don't know
for whatever reason i stopped doing that
but it reminds me of that it's kind of
similar may not be exactly the same no
it is it's very napoleon hill right in
think and grow rich napoleon hill has a
board of advisors who were his heroes
who had died he had abe lincoln on his
board of advisors he had all these
people and he would actually sit every
day and ask
all right how do i solve these problems
and you know we read it and think and
grow rich and we don't think it's that
weird but it's like
nowadays it feels really weird but it's
like why wouldn't we be using
all this support and wisdom
that's here we just have to ask for it
right is that a thinking girl rich maybe
that's where i took it from it is it's
in thinking
yeah
have time to reread the book i know such
a good book but i'm really excited i
will have to i want to share this with
you evan that your book is definitely
showing me that it would like to be done
in eight weeks
eight weeks
yeah it's shown me like four times so
i'm just gonna speak it doesn't mean you
have to but we're gonna open up this
space for massive momentum miracles
because this book is on momentum hold on
say that again massive momentum miracles
yes we're gonna open up the space for
massive momentum miracles and
because your book is seated in momentum
it would be really weird if it took a
long time to be birthed
right
it's supposed to come through super fast
i mean normally i like weird but but yes
in this case it's not it's not weird is
not good
i'm so excited for this book this book
is
like literally just so full of joy it's
so full of joy
someone's asking is matthew mcconaughey
on my board of advisors he wasn't
uh but but he he is now because he is
apparently the
the guy who whispered the book um
wild yeah it's one of those things you
never know what's gonna happen you open
yourself up and say hey let's go and
great things flow
um cool anything else from uh
you know maybe even on the fringe of
weirdness or came in uh
came in once that you want to share the
channel
let me feel into it really fast
the only other thing that just keeps
being shown to me is like i don't know
if you go to water parks with your 13
year old but you know when you like get
at the top of the slide and you're on
the tube and you just jump in and then
like you literally just go for the ride
of your life you're just having so much
fun your book keeps showing me like
that's what this experience will be it's
going to just be so much fun
and anytime it's not fun
i want you to look and say where am i
trying
to figure this out where am i
trying to be the voice instead of
channeling this book through because
this book is supposed to be a hundred
percent enjoy and fun as you bring it
through
okay
i'm so excited for you this is it
this is i gotta go find some i gotta go
find some cheer or some citrus what
about like uh
music or sunshine or water or like it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter i mean
i'm a big believer of if you feel good
you'll always channel easier right so if
you feel better in the sun go in the sun
if you feel better in under a heated
blanket go on a heated blanket i mean
like i have a literal year on my land
filled with drums and crystals and all
my favorite things and that's where i
like to channel because it's
it overlooks the mountains
and it's my sacred space but like i said
i've also written in trampoline parks so
once you've taught your body how to drop
into flow you can do it anywhere anytime
writing under a heated blanket
i've never done that but i like i like
it i like it i'm gonna write it down
um i kind of feel like we should do a
check-in in eight weeks
eight weeks so today we're filming this
on may 31st i don't know when it's gonna
hit youtube but may 31st is when we're
filming this
so what's eight weeks uh
eight weeks
would be
july 26th
done
okay
i think we should check in on the 26th
because here's the thing is if and and
honestly evan if you get stuck
just text me because i'm really like
committed to like supporting you and
bringing this book through right so 12
o'clock your time on 26 done
is round two on instagram
i'm so excited this is it this is the
process guys okay so before we leave can
we do a quick uh closure okay so we're
gonna do i want you to close your eyes
but i don't want to close the momentum i
need i need it to keep writing right
yeah yeah we're not going to close the
momentum but we're going to thank your
book okay so i'm a big like gratitude is
it's the magic of life right and so we
get to thank our angels for holding this
space thank our books for being here
right
and um only one angel showed up so we
gotta thank matthew
good vibes to matthew pretty big
all right here we go all right so take a
deep breath in
[Music]
pour this beautiful light through your
body we're just gonna wrap this book oh
my gosh this book is like so golden
brilliant
it's so enormous we're gonna wrap it and
so much love thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you we see you we
see you we see we see you this book is
coming through evan said yes
is here it's going to blast the world
with so much momentum and then we're
just going to hand the book over to the
divine and then we're just going to ask
all of your angels that they will
continue to hold you in momentum so that
this book will come with ease with grace
with light with joy with fun
with uh cheer
and we're just gonna thank them all for
holding the space take a nice deep
breath in
and then i want you to visualize this
golden path in front of you and it just
got opened up
it's a path that is literally paved with
gold
and
this path
as soon as you step on it with writing
your book is it's going to it's going to
wrap your whole life in this magic
momentum
and i want you to take a deep breath in
if you can visually you're visualize
yourself stepping on that path allowing
it to take you almost like um
the the moving sidewalks at the airport
we're just gonna let this path take you
exactly where it needs to go
and we're just going to wrap you in so
much light thank you thank you for being
open
for this magic that just went down so
thank you and um
ah we're complete with that
i love it well thank you kyra paulson
thank you matthew mcconaughey yes uh
we'll link up some stuff in the youtube
description as well to learn more about
where where do you want people to go to
learn about you is it is it the pdf or
the thing they're gonna you're giving
away well they can definitely click the
link where they can get the free
masterclass you can always follow me on
instagram which is carapalson they can
check out my publishing house which is
freedom house publishing co
all
online instagram all really simple but
the master class is going to give people
these tools and the pdf that you and i
were talking about
amazing awesome thank you very much to
do no i don't have work to do i have
fun fun to do so much fun yeah i got fun
to do and we'll see you on july 26th
fabulous thank you everybody for being
here
to see my one-on-one hypnotherapy
session with marissa peer check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there your mind number one
job is to keep you alive on the planet
hypnotherapy is super scary
it really isn't it's simply a way of
accessing
your subconscious mind